bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv
spéciale grands champions avec notre
habilité star jérôme maufras c'est le
gérant s'est lui stephen âmes a rappelé
que tu as évidemment aussi participé à
beaucoup de livres sur les échecs que tu
t'es beaucoup renseigné puis tu es aussi
professeur d'histoire donc tu as une
certaine passion comme ça pour
l'histoire aussi du jeu d'échecs tout
autant pour l'histoire des hommes en
général oui parce que l'histoire du jeu
d'échecs raconte aussi l'histoire du
monde
on a toujours observé dans l'histoire du
monde dans l'histoire des échecs y avait
un certain parallélisme à l'époque où le
monde arabo musulman se développe au
9ème 10ème siècle le monde
arabo-musulman à les plus grands
champions d'échecs les plus grands
théoriciens à l'époque de la renaissance
les champions sont italiens espagnols au
moment de la révolution industrielle les
champions sont anglais ou français et
ainsi de suite jusqu'à nos jours où
maintenant le champion du monde et
indien on a parlé à l'occasion du
championnat du monde récemment et il
fait partie d'une puissance émergente
donc il n'y a pas vraiment de hasard
l'histoire du jeu d'échecs que
l'histoire du monde se confondent et son
parallélisme et c'est assez amusant et
troublant à noter c'est ce qui fait
aussi l'intérêt de ce jeu est de l'étude
de son histoire
exactement et alors je pense que tu
remarqué importantes y compris dans les
changements profonds de la société
puisque là où le jeu d'échecs était
pratiquée par des dés
des citoyens je me dis oh des hommes
dans des situations plus ou moins
privilégiés fallait de l'argent pour
pouvoir jouer philidor par exemple mais
il avait une situation il était il était
musicien à la cour de louis 15 c'est pas
n'importe quoi bon ça lui permettait
aussi d'avoir de quoi vivre en plus des
quelques subsides qu'il a pu avoir après
par le jeu d'échecs mais peut-être moins
que en tant que musicien je sais pas
exactement mais mais un autre phénomène
qu'on va voir aujourd'hui puisqu'on va
parler d'une des premières championne du
jeu d'échecs et donc le mouvement
d'émancipation des femmes aussi
peut-être qu'il ya aussi là un autre
parent à lenny c'est à dire que tandis
que les femmes prennent de plus en plus
d'importance dans la société on les voit
apparaître au plus haut niveau dans le
jeu d'échecs alors aujourd'hui la
champion du monde en 2012 est une
chinoise de laon là aussi on voit les
grandes puissances qui émergent
notamment donc aux iphone à une chinoise
avec beaucoup de chinois est dans le top
10 mondial
mais la meilleure joueuse du monde est
aussi une des meilleures un des
meilleurs joueurs toutes catégories du
jeu d'échecs et qui d'ailleurs ne je ne
veux pas jouer le spécifiquement daytona
féminin c'est judith polynésie on voit
que les femmes donc progresse fortement
dans le jeu d'échecs d'ailleurs jamais
eu autant de grands maîtres
internationaux féminins
c'est dire que y apprendre tant il
n'avait pas aujourd'hui il y en a une
vingtaine
et puis au niveau simplement nationale
si on regarde les statistiques on a
maintenant 25 % de joueuses parmi les
licenciés alors qu'on en avait 10 % il
ya encore quinze ans voilà et
aujourd'hui on va avoir une grande
championne précurseur des échecs féminin
des années 20 30 voire 40 vers amitié
mais ramène chez quick qui a été reçu ce
qui est né à moscou qui était
nationalité de chèques mais tu sais
qu'ils avaient beaucoup de minorités
dans l'empiré russe jusqu'en 1914 elle a
joué le rôle de précurseur effectivement
elle a eu quelqu'un qui était avant elle
aussi précurseur qui s'appelait marie
roig qui était une anglaise qui a été la
première en 1872 à franchir
tiens toi bien les portes d'un club
d'échecs alors que c'était un univers
uniquement masculin et dans l'angleterre
victorienne
on n'imaginait pas qu'une femme puisse
comme ça
accomplir ce geste délirant et
outranciers d'aller déranger des hommes
pendant leurs activités ou marie roig
qui s'était d'ailleurs me raser les
cheveux comme les suffragettes pour
montrer qu'elle pouvait aussi avoir les
cheveux courts comme les hommes d'accord
ok mais la véritable et la première
grande championne sévère en belgique qui
va non seulement joué aussi bien que les
hommes mais va battre les plus forts
d'entre eux oui on des années 30
notamment aujourd'hui la partie star
qu'on va analyser qu'on va voir de
miramichi que c'est quand même une
victoire face à max hoff qui était
champion du monde quand même quelques
années plus tard ces deux trois ans plus
tard qui devient champion du monde en
battant alexander a li qin
quiconque a marqué le jeu d'échecs mais
celui là aussi été président de la
fédération internationale des échecs
plus tard dans les années soixante dix
et vire meetic l'a battu dans une très
belle partie mais l'a pas battue que à
labatut reach skis j'ai vu qu'elle avait
battue en thierry colombet qmi l'aise
tous les tous les grands joueurs de
cette époque quasiment soutane kahn ont
fait partie de ce qu'on a appelé le club
vers amène chic c'est à dire le club de
tous les hommes qui avaient été battus
par cette femme rappelé le club le club
et ramène chic oui il y avait un joueur
qui avait ironisé s'appelait albert
becker il avait ironisé quand elle avait
joué son premier tournoi parmi les
hommes en 1929 elle avait dit qu'il
faudrait créer un club et ramène chic
des hommes qui seraient battus et ils
avaient joué c'est la première partie du
tournoi contre elle et elle avait battu
ironie de l'histoire c'est le première
fois lundi qu'une langue du club il a
été puni pour son excès de misogynie
d'accord mais c'était
c'était une chose peu évidente qu une
fin même dans les années 20 30 joue dans
un tournoi dames 1 dans un premier temps
vers amène chic qui manifestement été
doué pour le jeu d'échecs est d'abord
devenu champion d'angleterre puisque ses
parents sont partis de russie en 1921
pour aller s'installer en angleterre est
devenue championne d'angleterre féminine
pour le premier championnat féminin qui
a existé en 1927 elle a conservé son
titre d' entre 1927 et 1930 set en
perdant une partie sur 83 partie de
championnat du monde féminin et en
faisant quatre nuls une seule partie par
une seule partie perdue ayant réussi à
défendre autant de fois son titre la
situation pour elle était mûr pour enfin
aller affronter les hommes parce que
c'était ça je crois sont son but et
l'appuyer dans la fin des années vingt
par participer à des tournois masculins
donc dans ce fameux son premier tournoi
elle a joué en remportant une partie
contre 1 albert becker et elle a eu des
résultats très très honorable
puisqu'elle a fini deuxième à ramsgate
en 1929 derrière capable en cas c'est
pas rien quand même
c'était pas rien il en parlant qu'un qui
est aujourd'hui encore il considéré
comme un des plus grands champions de
tous les temps de 60 ruches en plus mal
et exceptionnel mais quand on
reconstitue son classement elo est ce
qu'on peut le faire en refaisant les
calculs etc
je crois qu'il a plus de 2700 élever les
normes ce qui est pour l'époque c'est
vrai que ça se corse à le placer dans
les dix meilleurs du monde aujourd'hui
encore actuellement donc la fidh et la
deuxième en angleterre à kate derrière
kablan qu'elle a fini troisième à
maribor aussi dans un autre tournoi qui
était très relevé au point que aller qui
lui-même le champion du monde à la fin
des années 30 avait dit que c'était
quand même un petit peu misérable de
l'obliger quelquefois les à lui faire
perdre du temps a joué contre des femmes
défendre son titre de championne du
monde parce qu'elle avait rien à faire
dans des compétitions où il y avait des
joueuses de second rang et qui valait
mieux qu'elle joue avec les hommes parce
que elle était suffisamment forte pour
ça un conseil kaka que du coup à
pratiquer judit polgar absolument
puisque jeudi de paul gars tu l'as dit
ne joue plus depuis bien longtemps deux
tournois féminin et elle a fait partie
des meilleurs mondiaux elle a encore
fini troisième aux championnats d'europe
avec ses bains l'année dernière donc
c'est une grande championne mais avant
tout c'est un grand champion j'ai envie
de dire qu'il a une joueuse est avant
tout un joueur malheureusement pour vers
un banshee qu'il appelle le temps
peut-être de de pouvoir aller au bout de
sa démarche puisqu'elle est morte
tragiquement dans un bombardement
bombardements allemands en 1944 dans le
kent chez elle elle avait 38 ans qu'elle
n'a pas pu aller au bout de sa carrière
mais en tout cas elle a ouvert la voie à
tout un tas de joueuses qui après la
seconde guerre mondiale ont pu franchir
les portes des clubs d'échecs et puis
aussi participé au tournoi battre les
hommes
et puis s'imposer petit à petit puisque
c'est aussi un retour de gérer un retour
de bâton en tout cas remise au point de
l'histoire puisque les femmes jouaient
beaucoup au moyen-âge et vous avez
disparu des clubs d'échecs au moment de
l'entrée du jeu dans l'ère de la
compétition et elles sont revenus au jeu
plus récemment avec maintenant un belle
échoppe belle histoire en échec féminin
oui et des parties seront très très
intéressante en est de plus en plus ou
en colère maintenant le niveau monte
monte monte d'ailleurs yahia il ya plus
de au delà des grands maîtres féminin où
il ya plus d'une vingtaine il ya aussi
des de plus en plus de joueuses dans le
top 100 c'est à dire qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une pique au nord où il ya
aussi audi familia
il ya des moments de conduire ça pousse
ça pousse ça pousse et qu'on n'est pas
encore la parité
ça dépend des femmes là maintenant oui
mais la voie était tracée on peut dire
la voie était tracée la voie était
ouverte et vira menchov est parti alors
celles qui ont ouvert la voie
on va avoir quelques photos historiques
de cette grande championne précurseur
des échecs au féminin donc ce qui est
pas évident il faut se rappeler la
condition des femmes évidemment au début
du 20e siècle
c'est pas celle d'aujourd'hui c'est pas
celle du 21e donc il faut il faut
reconsidérer aussi l'effort représenté
ici dans ces conditions là donc on voit
ici une première photo alors c'est une
photo fantastique puisque nous avons
vers amélie face à alexandra liquide
quand même pas rien quand même
quand ils iraient quand même comme the
big boss des années 30 alors au fond à
gauche devait ramène chicas à gauche à
notre droite au fond on voit dans ma
roxy donc tu me dis que c'était son
entraîneur en ville a été son entraîneur
à partir de 1902 à partir du moment où
elle est arrivée en angleterre et
qu'elle a montré des dispositions pour
les échecs mais ses parents l'ont placé
sous la responsabilité de cet entraîneur
qui est qui est connu aussi pour avoir
laissé son nom à une variante de la
défense sicilienne
willow marocain bien sûr où une mare
rouge dont les taux le fameux des taux
de maroussi et qu'ils aient fait partie
des plus forts joueurs de l'époque est
là quand elle finit deuxième à ramsgate
en 1929 derrière capable en cas il fini
le tournoi devant marc au xix devant son
entraînement avant son entraîneur mais
c'est normal et l'infini par des partis
il m'a toujours toujours donc marosi lui
même ici et face à
un joueur envoyé deux types indien se
passe vous veillez à droite c'est
sultane cannes un magnifique joueur qui
faisait partie de ces météores indien
qui a eu aussi dans les mathématiques à
l'époque dans les années 20 il ya eu à
manu gens aussi dans les mathématiques
enseigne quelques comme ça quelques
étoiles filantes agnel génie absolu
je crois que c'est un petit âne kahn
était un un serviteur d'un riche anglais
je crois et qui lui laissait en quelque
sorte la possibilité de jouer quelques
tournois mais qui malheureusement la
sultane kahn ne pouvait pas forcément
jouer tout le temps qu'ils voulaient
puisqu'il devait le suivre dans ses
déplacements je crois que c'est le
joueur américain robin femme qui
racontait qu'il avait eu la surprise aux
olympiades d'être invitée chez ceux
riches anglais et d'être servi par
sultane car oui alors qu'il avait joué
quelques jours avant contrôles et passes
et oui assez particulier sultane cannes
et un est une énigme c'est un mystère il
a on ne sait pas où il apprit à jouer
aux échecs il est apparu du jour au
lendemain il a battu les plus forts
joueurs
oui un jour il est rentré e mail aux
cadres du mathématicien ravenne et j'en
ai pas mal aussi je crois que tous les
cas d n'diaye mais maintenant on oppose
poser des questions je veux dire tous
les indiens sont quand même dans une
sorte de voile mystérieux sera surtout
ils viennent et ce qu'ils font qui est
assez difficile à percer donc les
mystères de sultan khan seront peut-être
l'objet d'une wii et autres émissions
ouais ouais un joueur extrêmement
effectivement un énigmatique il faut une
fausse plancher dessus
donc on va voir une autre photo devait
ramène chic voilà ici donc c'est une
photo bon mais on perd un portrait
personnel voilà revenus à quoi elle
ressemblait avec elle bien qu'au final
mes clubs alors malheureusement voit pas
sa soeur sur les photos alors pourquoi
je parle de ça sur le gars va tout
simplement parce que quand tu verras
benchikha a été championne d'angleterre
pour la première fois sa soeur était
deuxième du classement
donc elle a eu aussi une joueuse
d'échecs qui jouait aux échecs d'accord
qui a profité de code comme une soeur
paule gardon qui m'impressionne comme ça
de la lignée familiale si on voit un
portrait là aussi on voit bien que c'est
un portrait puisqu'elle pose devait
ramène chimay de cette fois devant un
échiquier mais voilà c'est pas étonnant
quelle est la vraie qu'elle ait voulu
associer l'échiquier à ça voilà encore
une autre photo de véro machi on voit
bien la ressemblance est pas problème 1
et alors ici ça c'est pas une photo avec
mes racines chic celle là non c'est une
photo assez amusante même si on peut
dire qui date du milieu du 19e siècle
deuxième moitié du 19e siècle
on voit bien que ces messieurs joue et
les dames attendent à côté ça nous
montre un petit peu l'état de la société
à l'époque une femme de toute façon on
n'avait pas dans la société victorienne
où même dans les sociétés européennes à
l'époque le loisir de s'adonner à des
pratiques ludiques et des jeux de
société puisque les hommes se
retrouvaient dans des clubs qui étaient
fermés aux femmes
ouais et que les femmes étaient occupés
au foyer s'occuper des enfants etc etc
donc on voit bien ici qu'elles sont là
pour attendre que la partie se déroule
on imagine bien qu'elles n'ont pas leur
mot à dire non plus sur le déroulement
de la partie
heureusement tous a bien changé oui donc
ici on retrouve notre maroc si c'est ça
absolument desama roxy à l'époque où il
portait la moustache comme beaucoup
beaucoup d'hommes à l'époque et c'est
lui qui a
fait éclore le talent de vera mendy qui
était déjà bien présent mais il lui a
donné
sûrement quelques préparation théorique
quelques formations pour lui permettre
d'accéder au plus haut niveau dont
qu'entraîneur entraîneur de vera men
chic et enfin on finit par ici un
portrait assez pour retracer le contexte
de l'époque bien sûr ici en particulier
le contexte de la partie qu'on en voit
aujourd'hui devait ramène chic puisqu'il
s'agit de son adversaire le grand max up
champion du monde face à li qin et futur
président de la fédération
internationale des échecs
voilà le dr c'est un des plus grands
joueurs de l'époque et on va le voir
tomber dans une partie contre vera même
chic et on va voir que on peut supposer
qu'il a fait preuve d'un petit peu de
misogynie dans cette partie oui
exactement alors on va voir cette dans
cette partie effectivement typique mais
on va voir le talent de vermine chine
donc je vais passer à la partie donc
dans cette partie historique 1931
hastings grand tournoi sting c'est un
historique un cas toujours le d'ailleurs
un quick est toujours lieu c1 c'est le
plus grand pas le plus grand mais le
plus vieux tournoi du monde je crois que
c'est il ya peu d'endroits comme ça dans
un monde où le tournoi est aussi ancien
c'est un tournant qui est très ancien
dans une ville qui est un petit peu
désuète maintenant hastings et je suis
passé récemment et c'est un tournoi qui
se déroule leur général cheval entre
décembre et janvier de chaque année
on y verrait lui qui est toujours un
fort tour noire sur le
en angleterre sur la côte sud de
l'angleterre et qui réunissait à
l'époque va les plus forts joueurs donc
ici donc vers oman chic années 30 1931
face au futur puisque ces quelques
années plus tard qui devient champion du
monde la faute aux futurs champions du
monde max hub deraa
les blancs et c'est parti avec des
cadets lui fermé classique est bon une
réponse y mettrez avec des cinq est tout
de suite à ces quatre on voit que
l'ouverture et moderne déjà à l'époque
belle et les débuts de type fermé et
moderne commence à se populariser
puisque on sort quand même de l'époque
romantique au 19ème un peu avec les
grands et grands joueurs d'attaquer à
tout va mais là c'est beau un peu plus
positionnelle donc ces 4 et enfin ce qui
va nous déterminer l'ouverture c6 on est
dans une slave
un coup qui a été remis à la mode
relativement récemment par vladimir
kramnik un coup qu'on a vu jouer lors
des précédents championnats du monde et
qui est très solide
l'idée des noirs étant bien sûr si les
blancs prennent avec l'option ces quatre
des cinq de pouvoir reprendre avec leurs
pions et ramener un pion vers le centre
voilà et ne pas jouer aussi ce qui est
plutôt le grand midam classique pour
laisser la possibilité aux fous si vite
pourquoi pas de sortir en faisant un
coup j'ai quatre donc les noirs ont
assez d'attendre au maximum de voir
comment les blancs se développe avant de
décider de fermer ou pas la négo nal de
ce fou pour pouvoir le sortir donc ça
donne plus de souplesse 2 par rapport à
ce fou que le cou aux six par contre
évidemment le coup libérateur c5 est
bien reporté à plus tard parce que dans
avec le 6 on veut jouer csn vite aussi
bien sûr donc cavalier f3 bon très bien
qu'elle ait aussi ce qu'avait laissé
trois ferme ainsi que pour l'instant
pratique les principes sacrés
d'ouverture les cavaliers avant les fous
contrôle du centre on voyait qu'on a
poussé le pion c'est pour faire pression
avant de sortir les cavaliers elle a pas
peur ici
prise sur ces quatre puisque ça lui
permettrait d'envahir le centre par
quatre et pourquoi pas ensuite 5
donc elle sait déjà faire les gambie
classique il n'y a pas de problème donc
dépensé 4 il faut faire attention ici
alors bien sûr alors on peut on peut le
cadre à jouer on peugeot cas c'est très
dangereux c'est là c'est un peu les
standards d'aujourd'hui de plus c'est le
cas tout de suite et puis de laisser
faire et à mai vers un mythe il joue un
peu plus prudent une autre variante tout
à fait jouable aussi qui est l'autre
possibilité parce que s'ils ont joué
quatre évidemment se heurtent on se
heurte entre guillemets à bessens qui
protège le pion c4 mais qui laisse
pousser ou 5 après cavaliers des 5 et
puis cavaliers leucate les blancs en
gros avantage centrale mais un pion de
moins bons c'est un pion de côté bon
mais on peut choisir aussi de lire
maintenant je veux pas laisser un pion
de plus je préfère patienter un peu je
joue à 4 donc j'empêche simplement mais
c'est un conte plus apprise prise donc
on peut pas pousser
mais c'est donc là par contre le
problème ne peut faire le problème
la contrepartie d'avoir joué le 4 c'est
que les blés noirs peuvent profiter de
leur idée d'ouverture ici d'avoir joué
ces six c'est de ne pas avoir bouché le
fou ces huit par le 6 août ou début
puisqu'on peut jouer fou obsèques
on fait deux choses ici on développe le
fond et on empêche le 4 et on empêche le
4 voilà on contrôle ici à noter que
souvent le coût de sortie du fou est
contrecarrée par la dame qui vient
attaquer 17 et il ya un problème sur les
cases blanches ici pas facile à résoudre
mais on peut pas ici il ya un pion donc
coup fort est suffisant deux oeuvres de
max rêve ici fouet le 5 très jolie
réponse tout à fait standard de vermine
chic et classique le 3 maintenant très
vite il faut eh bien allez reprendre le
pion donné évidemment bon mais on a
accepté de ne pas pousser aux quatre
tout de suite on a est quand même
majorité centrale on a deux qui ont
contraint donc on peut envisager de
poussée de quatre plus tard et ont joué
trois dans l'idée de prendre ces quatre
et simplement d'abord sortir le fou plus
d'avoir un petit oeil sur cette
diagonale et départ hockey et des prix
aux rockets
cavalia six bons
cool normal de maxwell il sort le
cavalier pourquoi si c'est bien parce
que comme les blancs jouent à 4 on a ici
une case qui n'est plus attaquées par un
kurde on sait qu'une case faible on va
pouvoir venir sur la case b 4 en venant
des quatre éventuellement pourrait
surcontrôlés detroit on peut aussi sur
contrôler ces deux avec la fameuse
fourchette on va mourir
roy et puis quand on est sauté ici en d4
and carry on peut sur protéger le
cavalier part à cinq avec une belle
position
voyez que les blancs pas l'équivalent
d'un les mettre leurs cavaliers sur une
case comme ça donc ils profitent de
cette faiblesse la en contrepartie
attention ils ont deux filles ont
contraint il ya un seul coup ici
vraiment acceptable c'est simplement fou
prend ses 4 j'élimine le pion ckac à
plus de faiblesse sur la case d3 et sur
cavalli beckham qui menace la fourchette
il suffit d'éviter l'échec par le coup
naturel petit rock c'est fini et là
peut-être le coup naturel aurait été de
jouer à 5 ici pour les noirs pour
consolider le québec parce que le
cavalier noir en bkt sur un bel avant
postes il ne peut pas être chassé ne
peut pas être chassé toute sa ruse sauf
par une pièce voilà mais si on joue pas
à 5 on peut se heurter à sa une de la
part des blancs et il est pas très
stables ce cavalier enfin parce qu'il
peut être attaqué par des pièces si on
joue à 5 c'est fini il est plus on peut
plus rien faire contre lui il est devenu
trop forts pour eux aussi ce bon tu sais
c'est pas c'est pas mauvais non plus
monsieur robert ces mauvais donc eu 6
c'est bien alors l'idée de 6 c'est pas
tellement de protéger sa mais surtout de
pouvoir sortir le fou suite et enfin de
préparer l'europe peut-être à 5 d'abord
aux 6 pourquoi pas assez un an plus tard
on va voir ici permettiez xu caihou cinq
coups naturel en a fini le rock bon mais
ma foi qu'est ce qui reste à faire il ya
plus peu fou là à sortir mais pour
l'instant il est un peu bloqué ici c'est
pas forcément terrible de m
les deux cavaliers 5 on a un cavalier au
centre et puis on peut menacer regarder
le truc classique s'est jouée f3 on joue
ici contre les cases blanches contre le
catholicisme est aussi on joue pour
pousser le 4 et une fois qu'on a joué 4
on a un très beau stade et on peut
sortir le fou en trois ans jai 5
on a un très beau jeu donc le 5 pourquoi
pas qu'elle vient 5 ça peut être joué en
conjonction avec ce genre de coups bon
boxeur
pour l'instant ce ne veut pas jouer la
scène toujours je sais pas moi je rejoue
assène je pense même le coup d'avant
mais bon oui porte cavaliers non par des
satyres rock e6 curieux c et food et 6
pour préparer le petit rock bien sûr des
six alors on peut hein ah c'est de
prendre le 5 aussi mon attention parce
que ça pourrait casser la structure des
pions des pions blancs
ça peut être une idée mais on prépare
surtout le petit rock bon pourquoi allez
venir à 1,7 alors que les blancs ne
peuvent pas jouir g5 c'est pas utile en
décision n'est plus actif en
transparence du cavalier cible un jour
on peut attaquer la case age 2 pourquoi
pas et laure joly could vers métriques
tranquillement j'aime bien traditionnels
super moi j'ai alors ça c'est super
c'est un très joli coup dans l'esprit la
position pourquoi bas ou quatre circuits
si la dame de bain non seulement permet
pourquoi pas la tour d un de faire un
vis-à-vis tournant donc commence à
connecter les tours mais surtout bain et
protège la plus de 4 même l'or en
évitant f3 s'est passé pas si mal donc
c'est très bien c'est dans l'esprit nos
positions ça veut dire qu'elle a
parfaitement compris tous les éléments
positionnelle moderne dans un tournant
moderne ça tout ça c'est correct
alors qu'est-ce qui se passerait sur fou
prend 1,5 ici alors vous prendre 5
serait envisageable
pourquoi pas simplement on prend et
bombay sacré déjà du problème sur le
cavalier m6 et puis ça fait rien contre
la poussée ou 4 voilà alors sur par
exemple un coup comme cavalier ou 4
alors que ce qu'on pourrait faire
simplement on pourrait prendre
on peut prendre le cavalier fou prend et
pourquoi pas effectivement le classique
dames g4 attaque le fou et le pion g7
s'étaient oblige voegele 6 bis rouge et
6 et là on regarde on peut envisager
pourquoi pas fonds prend aussi ce
intéressant
pourquoi ligne c'est un sacrifice oui
mais regardez au cavalier derrière donc
ce genre de choses
attention là les noix les noirs sont
quand même
on peut sont patinées développer on peut
aussi jouer tour d un attaquant la dame
où va la dame alors si la dame bien on
sait cette c'est bien mais ça n'empêche
pas fou prend 2,6 et même pire parce que
menace aussi échec menace aussi pourquoi
pas tour 17
et si on prend et et bien d'un prend des
4 es le roi ne peut même pas manquer
puisque la dame empêchent leurs hommes
de ce côté et la tour empêche le rock
d'un autre côté donc conclusion après
dingue 2 foot prend des six c'est pas
forcément meilleurs vous prendre 5
pardon il faut prendre un set partout
précise fu prend cavalli n'est pas bon
pour toutes ces raisons
attention aux cavaliers en l'air donc ça
va dans le sens de ce que je disais moi
j'aime bien consolider mes pièces
d'avancé le dire c'est pour ça que me 5
quand même ça m'aurait plu
alors au lieu de quoi alors là peuvent
alors là il pourrait encore jouer avant
de re ok parce qu'il n'est pas pressé il
peut tenter à saint pourquoi pas bon
mais il ya au kenya le cadre bien sûr
une suppression un voleur ici il n'y a
pas forcément
peut-être que va n'a pas aussi bien
compris finalement cette position ce
système positionnelle que verra que vers
à mennecy kiss-in anciennes positions
mais peut-être que comme il comprend pas
les idées il fait des gaffes dire il me
semble moi je veux dans cette position
c'est le genre de position on aime jouer
à 5
c'est le coût nature il faut consolider
le voit dans la combinaison commune voir
à quoi ça sert d'avoir concilier ce
point au lieu de quoi on regardait fait
alors une gaffe
presque oui je pense que je vais un peu
chevronnés pour l'éviter c'est grave
quand même non oui parce qu'il a par ok
le roi est toujours au centre
le roi est toujours au centre c'est le
bon moment pour éventuellement rock et
pourquoi pas on peut jouer à 5
attention quand même parce que la dame
est face au moins bon il faut pas non
plus faut pas laisser exploser le centre
comme ça les mecs se lance un petit peu
un petit peu tôt sabre au clair parce
que la poussée ces cinq points terrains
y ait la paix sociale est intéressante
mais simplement laisse la possibilité
aux glandes je fous mais cinq échecs
exact c'est le point qu'il faut quand
même s'arrêter là-dessus pour tricia de
la partie au lieu de rockets au lieu de
l'actuel 1 consolidé son son son point
avance ici est bien un homme se lance
dans une aventure risquée
il joue le coup c'est sec peut-être
qu'il en fait ils on peut dire aussi
peut-être que à ce moment là il se dit
bon mais je sais pas davantage
quand je me vois mal ne pas gagner la
partie face à vera benchikh parce que
j'ai pas envie d'y jouer deux tournois
dans ces conditions ça ça va être
difficile et il se lança peu à
l'abordage pour essayer d'en finir quoi
et d'essayer de déstabiliser la joueuse
bon c'est 5 et un coup quand même un peu
olé olé parce que voyez bien bros
au départ le puits ont été en sait si
c'était pour limiter les pousser bon il
vous csn pourquoi pas mais il faut
attendre le bon moment pour le faire on
a même par ok on n'a pas consolidée
vraiment encore la position d'autres
avant postes et puis surtout vers ans
saute sur l'occasion
parce que il ya surtout pas fou de 5
which alors ça fait mal parce que échec
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire mais rien
parce que si on sent si on met le cap à
l'est devant l fou prend un bain une
pièce où ta venue prendre pièce net et
si on met un cavalier des quatre ans et
six dans les brancards et les prend puis
on prend puis on prend fou prend les
chèques et autres on ramasse la tour par
avec un gain net un cavalier une qualité
nette avance donc elle n'a plus le choix
il doit tout le court 7
alors c'est peut-être qu'ils voulaient
jouer il se dit finalement au roi est
pas plus mal ici j'ai connecté mais tour
il recommandé à vis de la dame
ouais le roi écart vis-à-vis de la dame
les pièces blanches sont toutes
développer le centre a pas été
consolidés
j'ai un cavalier qui n'est pas
clairement clairement à l'aise je peux
faire sauter ce python tard ce pion et
ce cavalier les psys sans défense il est
en avance mais il n'est pas protégé et
surtout ça n'empêche pas eu 4 et surtout
ça n'empêche pas le fameux e 4 dont on
appareils depuis le début quand même un
monstre de d'attac qui va libérer le fou
qui va pouvoir les phocéens qui va
pouvoir les anges et 5 avec un courage
des cavaliers surnommé roi qui va très
très plaisant d'ailleurs magnifique ou
d' attaque derrière de vue ramène tiki
donc keith harris pas content et il dit
mais coûte 3 n'est pas top parce que tu
vas voir
regarde bien et alors là ça ça fait mal
parce que là maintenant ça y est elle y
va direct elle attaque le fou il sait qu
elle prend position sur le centre on
voit mais ce pion il a presque envie
d'avancer à 1,5 pour attaquer fouet
cavalier blanc ni tout yann cavaillé là
oui mais justement je peux l'enlever
créer des menaces et poussé aux cinq
derrière il ya énormément de menaces il
ya un roi en face de la dame
ça fait peur moi je j'aimerais pas je
voulais finir cette partie ou alors
uniquement pour me lancer pour lancer un
défi pour voir si l'adversaire est
capable de gagner mais c'est quand même
pas une position agréable à jouer
d'offres d'une pour passer ses pas on
peut pas dire que c'est un début réussi
non là il ya quasiment une pièce de
perdu déjà puisque le fou alors on
pouvait attaquer il faut bien crise
quelque chose imaginons le coup ici
c'est de pousser prendrait quatre on va
essayer de suivre une variante quand
même c'est prendre les quatre bon tu
m'attaques un fou mais je contre attaque
sur le cavalier comprends je prends
quand même et sur pions prend ces trois
mais quatre attaques ici cavaliers f7
quelle épreuve ça je n'en peux envisager
et c'est exactement je peux envisager
car les premiers sets ça fait mal et
comme amitié puis on prend et d'emprunts
échec c'est une possibilité mais je peux
aussi envisagée
simplement puis on prend 1,6 c'est bien
aussi si on prend 1,6 je peux pas
prendre avec le roi puisque cavaliers
bouge échec par la dame et le kawaï
ensuite va prendre la dame noire et si
je prends du bio j'ai quand même regardé
ici il suffit que je prenne le large et
je vais pouvoir doubler et je vais
pouvoir sortir le cavalier est allé
prendre 6 avec un quasi maths ça sera
très dur pour les noirs main ça fait
quand même mal
donc là on peut pas dire que la cette
position soit viable le roi est quand
même en plein dans la bataille en plein
milieu des fossés des forces ennemies
devant une colonne semi-ouverte une
pression terrible sur lui on peut dire
que la partie est presque presque dix
ans que des grands maîtres actuels
n'accepterait pas y jouer ça je pense
pas que kasparov et ce genre de position
dans sa préparation avec les noirs c'est
donc à eux quatre très fort coût 1
c'est fort parce qu'il ya quand même
plein de combinaisons ici on peut
prendre on peut prendre le 5 mai à
lorient ainsi s'il faut prendre 5
simplement reprend des pions on a de
bien attaquer mais voilà il s'est perdu
ils ont un père une donc fou et 6 hors
coûts encore possible et là regardez
c'est simple cavaliers prend un nouvel
epr en échec et après échec au vent et
messieurs on comprend des pions et ça y
est la fourchette
ça fait mal des six des sites fourchette
avec échec
oui alors c'est pour ça que ses rangs
des caps ne suffit pas alors ils jouent
car elle s'éprend d'écart 3 max oeuvre
il ay contre attaque le cavalier mais
away alors c'est très joli ce qu'elle
joue d'ailleurs un pré derrière parce qu
elle ne reprend pas tout de suite ne
prend pas tout de suite à ces tours d un
pas mal tourné un regard dit elle prend
pas tous deux auraient pu prendre la
pièce avec échec mais non elle prend
tourné en dix ans mais coûte vas-y
prends parce que si tu prends simplement
en garde je vais faire tout reprendre
des six attaques la dame et après on
tuellement je te prendrais je te
prendrai avec un roi ici qui va se
prendre en fout prendre fouet le 4 avril
imaginons par exemple ici que la dame
joue ensuite à nancy d'accord on peut
éventuellement alors prendre et 6 ou
même chose mais se prend
ces trois tout c'est oui ou un non
pensée pensée encore plus fort parce que
si on prend ces trois cavaliers par
exemple en d5 france était l'ambiance
est énorme ici paf
outch c'est à dire qu'on menace tourist
échec
enfin tout bouge en c6 et le fou fait
échec on peut aussi prendre le cavalier
avec l'échec floraux ont regardé ce roi
et il est en jeu quoi tout un ange
c'est tout à fait pas je vois c'est
complètement pas jouable donc ici c'est
prend des cartons bien c'est très très
fort c'est très très fort la menace est
plus forte que l'exécution non mais
c'est une partie magnifique parce que
elle elle ne se pressent pas pour
prendre l'aventage elle joue des coûts
encore plus fort que de prendre un
avantage direct
elle va chercher les coûts dynamique
c'est le genre de coups qu'on verrait
voir jouer un crâne est qu un énorme de
moderne comme generis me précipiterai
pas forcément sur la prise immédiate et
les rues des coûts intermédiaires qui
renforce encore plus la pression sur le
mois et demi qui permettent de gagner la
pièce sans perte de l'initiative ni la
dynamique exactement tout à fait donc
alors ici des oeuvres se résout à sortir
le fou de du vis-à-vis pour que la dame
ici protège le plan des 4 mai par
ailleurs ça cloue le pion et le cavalier
c3d blanc devient imprenable voilà le
coeur n'y était pas on savait qu'ils
allaient perdre une pièce adjacente
elle n'a fait que rajouter de la
pression l'intermédiaire est maintenant
vers à meetic prend un f6 alors faut pas
rendu plongée on va pas mettre leur ont
encore plus dans les courants d'air un
fils est là simplement attention puisque
après l'échec en prise il ya une petite
menace quand même de max eux il faut pas
l'oublier
attention ici ce serait dommage de
gâcher cette magnifique position par un
oubli donc elle joue le coup tranquille
jetteront donc à noter qu'un pic du
couloir on a totalement annihilé la
halle attaque ici sur 7 sur 7
cette colonne
donc c'est un excellent ici de jouer
alors il choisit de jouer à 6 alors
assise pour faire sortir ce fou alors
attention mais sûr parce que si les
blancs par un artifice arrive à ouvrir
cette colonne des six latour venez en
dix-sept protégé par le fou faire en
échec ce serait mortel donc en jouant
ainsi son s'enlève un fou ni contrôle
des cases important dans le camp ennemi
mais se précipite pas encore une fois
elle le joue fouet 3 c'est magnifique le
nombre de coûts intermédiaires que le
sens est parti un fou et 3 donc alors
évidemment il alla alors qu'est ce qui
se passe sur puis on prend fou mais en a
[ __ ] en d4
on pourrait le faire tout reprendre et 4
on pourrait faire tourner ça sert un peu
plus compliqué ouais c'est plus
compliqué puisqu'il ya le oui mais il se
serait quand même fort ça sera quand
même fort mais fou prend des 4 semble
encore plus fort et c'est encore plus
fort vous prend et 4 ce qu'on menace
plusieurs choses aux menaces fous ces
cinq échecs menace de la dame et
attaques du cavalier qui traînent en d4
on attaque à la fois la dame des 8es en
plus en menace de prendre en plus le
cavalier le cas avec la première menace
de l'autre côté fou prend réussissent
échapper aux menaces beaucoup de choses
et si les noirs ici faisait un coup
comme
imaginons roi 8 pour éviter l'échec mais
dans ce cas la durée quand même fou ces
cinq là tour attaque
la dame et la dame ne peut pas vraiment
défendre ne peut pas du tout même
défendre le cavalier là pas de coût pour
défendre le cas il faut qu'elle sorte de
l'attaqué elle a pas beaucoup de choix
faut qu'elles viennent ici ou ici et
j'ai simplement on va reprendre la pièce
avec un gros avantage plutôt le roi est
encore plus
aux fraises j'ai envie de dire si les
couples y aura des en plus il a coupé
les tours donc il est sur l'amitié mais
tout c'est pas bon donc fou et 3 donc
qu'est ce qu'on a dit alors assure
apprend bessin il faut prendre des 4
qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer d'autres
surfent ou prendre les quatre sur m'en
fous des six quelque chose quant à l'or
il ya la possibilité oui bien sûr de
jouer food et 6 ça c'est oui c'est le
coup le plus naturel donc fou des six en
bouche l'attaqué tour apparemment
apparemment en bouche l'attaqué tour
dames et en plus on donne une petite
protection aux cavaliers b4 mais on peut
quand même je fous ces 5 on peut quand
même joué vous ce serait de toute façon
un peu comme jouer c'est simple puisque
après il faut passer cinq tours panda
mais toujours avantage surtout qui peut
suivre dernière dame prend b5 attaque le
fou attaque le cavalier le cube est ce
être un tout voilà voilà donc cesser
c'est quand même c'est quand même très
très mal parti
donc après foulée 3 eh bien il se résout
le max juifs au v6 alors sans doute
faible et 6 pourquoi pour deux raisons 1
il protège bien sûr des cadres et de
heath ménage une sortie pour la dame
parce qu'il commence à comprendre que
finalement ce vis-à-vis est intenable
ça devient pénible voilà donc foulée 6
et là maintenant c'est l'heure pour
vervins type de jouet poussé quatre
tranquillement et ça y est note max hoff
commence à comprendre aussi qu'il vaut
mieux qu'ils enlèvent le roi du
vis-à-vis par rapport à la dame enfin
tout il aurait mieux fallu qui s'en
occupe avant et enfin maintenant
regarder ça c'est joli donc cac valeo 4
et bien l'idée de cavale et aux quatre
allers simples c'est qu'on commence à
faire pression aussi sur le plan et 6 on
a une pression sur les cases du côté
du côté noir ici aussi donc
il faut maintenant prendre des mesures
du côté noir contre ça en plus du reste
et ça devient pénible notamment sauf
qu'a lieu 4 on peut aussi envisager les
dames f3 qui font pression sur m6 il est
noir jouef singles mais toutes les cases
noires ici sont totalement sous pression
le fou va se balader et plein de choses
à faire ici mais sur f5
on a fouillé 5 par exemple on peut avoir
forgé celle qu'on peut avoir
cavalier aussi j'ai c'est un cas ça peut
être très très dangereux avec des
menaces de fou prend 1,6
un suivi de calais prend 1,6 fourchette
roi-dame la fameuse fourche et royal un
très joli donc roi g7
il comprend samax heures à l'intérieur
c'est long et tout ça il aurait mieux
fait de roque et voyez le nombre de
coups qu'il a perdu 1 2 3 alors qu'un
coup la tour était un jeu là en juin ça
mais il permet d'envisager de mettre sa
tour en jeu il met une petite défense
avait le roi sur le coup j'ai six noms
n'aime pas trop défendre dans défendre
un pion avec le roi c'est toujours
dangereux parce qu'il peut y avoir des
sacrifices de traction
ça fait peur parce que là ce on a
presque envie de sur un cavalier mais
bon c'est un peu tôt parce qu'elle adam
1 mais peut passer jacente pas mettre
une tour à la défense le fou il pour
l'instant il est pris là il peut pas y
revenir en défense il faut et le cahier
il peut être pris à tout moment s'il
vient dé 5,6 et un point c'est le poète
pénible
alors toi c'est un tranquille c'est joli
là mais sa dernière pièce en jeu est
magnifique ce parti en termes de
standards de comment comment battre un
joueur qui qui vous traitent très mal
les principes d'ouverture elle est
magnifique retour h5 lança c'est un joli
coup de manoeuvre de m
puisque il met en jeu une tour qui est
un peu hors jeu pour essayer de
contrôler des cas centrale donc ça c'est
bien elle peut revenir en jeu pourquoi
pas un f5 pour tenir le plus réussi ce
ça peut être bien
bon on n'aime pas trop mettre en jeu des
tours trop loin parce qu'elles sont au
contact des pièces mineurs donc on n'a
pas envie d'échanger une grosse pièce
lourdes essentiel en fin de partie
contre une pièce légère mais s'il n'y a
pas le choix faut pas oublier quand même
une pièce de moins mais en échange la
pièce de moins bon il ya quand même deux
pions il a deux pions centraux ans puis
un semblant de début des attaques sur le
roc blanc peut-être le projet de doubler
les tours ou de jouer là d'avancé 7 et
de jouer pour rendre ses sept tours oui
c'est vrai c'est possible effectivement
ou torrent ou damage suit aussi il peut
essayer mais attention si metro de
pièces la cc le roi noir qui va en pâtir
aussi ça peut être très dangereux
notamment il ya la 9-3 attention il ya
tours fc nation est encore un peu de jeu
pour les noirs c'est pas totalement
perdue ils allaient ils sont moins bien
sûr mais c'est pas totalement perdu
alors fou et 4,08 chiffres f4 alors
évidemment comme l ami le cac valeo 4 et
qu'on a vu que le contrôle et la casse
des six on voit tout de suite l'intérêt
de faut être quatre on peut envisager
décalé des six pour attaquer bessette
pour attaquer f7 parce que si on
attaquait vii ou apprend dame prend a
soutenu par le fouet seimat
on va très fermes atteint 27,1
ça va être terrible donc attention
attaque sur le pion par transparence on
protège h 2 oui c'est vrai c'est
vraiment on a un petit oeil pourquoi pas
sur h2 ça peut ça peut jouer un rôle par
exemple sur damas chuiton pourriez
envisager g4 attaque la tour et protège
h2o avec le fou pourquoi pas pas
forcément le mieux mais on sait jamais
aux 5
alors elle oblige alors ça c'est
toujours mauvais quand on a des pions
doublé là en paquets comme ça de les
bouger là parce qu'en jouant ce coup
mais on affaiblit cette diagonale donc
ça y est on tapisse il avec les blancs
aussi sur la cassette qui est quand même
si bien le point névralgique annuel a
été de la position mois si on arrive à
faire sauter simple c'est moi c'est
perdu l obliger à jouer cinq donc c'est
jouer à g4 c'est magnifique c'est super
bien joué à lorient nancy et noir
prennent ici il ya des pions triplé
c'est l'horreur et en plus on prend la
tour dont prend la tour et là la tourner
qui était venu là aussi pour contrôler
l'échiquier de façon transversale belle
tout comme myriam les objets de revenir
en arrière
donc c'est superbe c'est très bien joué
puisque fou g3 donc c'est magnifique
parce qu'elle a joués fouet f4 en ayant
vu que sur 1 5 kg 4 et à taux étant
obligé de partir un magnifique poste en
g3 puisqu'à la fois ce fouillis défensif
on a mis un pion à bien potentiellement
contact de l'ennemi d'avoir un contrôle
peut être la poussée f5 mais aussi ça
peut aider à la poussée g5 qui peut
faire casser contre totalement la chaîne
de pions et demi en cas de prise
évidemment ces fous qui revient échec au
roi
il ya tout qui saute donc ce pion elle
peut être un bélier totalement
destructeur
c'est une très belle position c'est très
très bien joué le cavaliere elle est
comme elle est magnifique ici en terme
de pression se foulent superbe regarder
un échange de quoi le fruit pas si ce
cavalier des enjeux et des en l'air plus
il est à angleur ça veut dire qu'il est
protégé par rien il peut faire l'objet
d'une prise de fait ne variant tu cette
tour est à peine active et celle là est
totalement hors jeu et là on aime la
menace cavaliers f6 direct
kylie proxis on à la menace tout à fait
bienvenu car les problèmes 6 parce que
imaginons que les noirs jouent un compte
et on va on va faire un coup comme un
saint etienne c'est pas l'heure de jouer
accès à scène parce que regarder car les
problèmes 6 août
pourquoi parce que sur roy prend f6
dal35 mat
le roi n'a plus de cases in et mat la
dame est protégé par le fou et le roi
s'il retombe il toujours en échec par
adam et les gilets en échec par tous et
si la dame prend c'est le fou qui prend
un très joli mais vu jérôme un
magnifique les magnifiques faut prendre
5 avec attac de la dame et clouage
injection clouage le clouage royal et on
gagne la dame et la partie avec très
bien très bien vu elle est pleine de
rouler plein de possibilités cette
partie donc dames 7 n'empêche pas
qu'elles les points m6
oui mais elle ne fait pas grève ne joue
pas elle aurait pu le faire donc qu'elle
aurait pu s'y faire car il prend m6 avec
un taux de jouer parce que ensuite
évidemment on se doute que les noirs ne
vaut pas prendre ni avec le roi ni avec
la dame mais ça empêche pas ensuite de
faire fou preuve que ça empêche pas
faire comprendre cinq d'autant plus que
si ce contrôle la case 8
donc on va pouvoir prendre une tour qui
viendront ici et sa menace aussi qu'à
valider cinq qui fait une clouage fait
une fourchette pas assez calé prend ici
c'est mortel
ces offres ne le voit pas apparemment
donc là elle joue qu'à aller des deux
cas et d2 alors c'est pas mauvais quand
validé deux rien c'est moins fort que
cali pour m6 c'est dommage qu'elle est
comme ça mais ça reste aussi il sera est
fort puisque après tour h18 bon logique
de versailles il même jour en face à
tours ça il n'ya vu par là ça marchait
pas et attendent beaucoup parce que
l'euro à d'abord indiqué je vais
finalement je vais aller là la tour je
vais là-bas sinon je me perds du temps
en attendant les langues perdu aucun
temps et là regardez alors l'idée de
l'hermétique lé film puisque elle joue
d'un me 4 elle a remplacé en fait est là
et c'est dit après estimation que la
dame ici serait mieux que le cac est
donc elle se presse pas alors même le
cavalier dans une position qui est pas
si mal parce qu'elle peut peut-être plus
recyclé ce qu'elle valait sans doute sur
la case f3 en f3 elle rajoute de la
pression sur 5 donne de la puissance au
cou g5 g5 je fais sauter f6 ou si on
prend ça me permet d'aller prendre le
pion central et si le pion central tombe
l'autre qui on va tomber aussi toi avec
invasion ensuite des pièces blanches qui
ont rappelons le est sans surnuméraires
donc il va y avoir un souci donc dames 4
sur les cases blanches dame 17 bien ça
c'est dû jouer tranquille mais la case
la dame sur 17 maintenant cette fois c
est les noirs qui ont misé avis tour
napt mohegan sun un pion ici et là voilà
kf3 donc en fait la même s'il a pas pris
un f6 qui était peut-être en tout coup
tactique plus fort
cette variante est pas forcément moins
bonne parce que ella elle l'a fait j'ai
presque midi à une combinaison carpeaux
viennent parce qu'elle a recyclé
le positionnement de ces pièces en deux
coups un caïd et deux dans le caca
l'e313 coubon elle a replacé la vue est
une façon d'améliorer en fait la
position de ces pièces à noter qu'ici en
quatre ans contrôlent toujours g4
lecavalier 3 fait pression sur la chaîne
de pions noirs
il ya plus que ça à faire sauter or elle
a tout fait pour mettre en place le
verrons le déverrouillage dams et six
sur la tentative alors rêve comprend que
c'est intenable
il y joue dams et six en essayant de
soulager son camp par des échanges et
véronique se concentrent des changes feu
dame prend ses six car les processes les
noix respirante pluie si oui mais en
même temps ils échangent des pièces et
comme ils ont une pièce de retard oui
exactement c'est quand même un souci
c'est quand même souci donc food et sec
ça fait très jolie tranquille attaque
alors menace carrément fou prend alors
même si les tours viennent défendre on
peut prendre puisque ça crée un pion
doublé d'un fin corruptions isolées
on peut envisager de prendre on va voir
on peut aussi envisager après tour à ses
huit fouet car voilà la remplacer la
dame dans la foule elle tient absolument
à voir une pièce ici à la raison c'est
très important parce qu'il faut pas que
les noirs puisse pousser le 4 way ça
alors ça donnerait du poids leurs pions
centraux ce rebond ne rêviez alors pour
voilà on l'a fait c'est vrai on peut se
demander d'ailleurs si vous n'êtes pas
eu intérêt si jouer car il incarne le 4
l pour essayer de se donner du jeu
puisque sur quatre bombes sur ip
rampillon après faut prendre ces six
baies prend ces six équipes non c'est
pas possible
pire les pions sont intéressés c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible parce que
même trois là c'est pas dans ça ça ne
laisse en rien le fou de toute façon qui
protège on va perdre encore le pion ces
six noms century peut pas il peut pas
donc là après fou dessins qu'il faut
qu'ils protègent il n'a pas le choix et
fougueux 4 donc tour c'est cette non
pourquoi pas ton c7 alors peut-être
qu'il veut doubler sans doute pourquoi
pas je vois je vois rien d'autre toute
façon alors soit doubler ici seaux d'eau
mais là je pense que plus tôt l'autre
côté et cabrio 1
alors encore une manoeuvre tranquille
cavaliers 20 pour venir évidemment des
3l créer ce qu'on appelle des des
bloqueurs à la halle aux cavaliers
bloqueurs en d3 - qui va non seulement
empêcher l'avancée du pion des wii et
qui va aussi protéger la casse c'est un
en cas de doublement des tours ça fera
toujours au nom des échanges tout à fait
la pièce qu'il faut pour aller récupérer
après les échanges la tour c est
exactement dans quel recycl'aisne rossi
que ces pièces tranquillement une par
une elle se presse pas tout rose élites
et la lune prend tranquillement
carlos est de havanes pour lui c'est le
moment il faut essayer de soulager la
pression alors regardez quand même plus
haut il ya des changes malheureusement
pour lui
plus la différence de pièces va avoir
lieu bon il ya un pion pour la pièce
mais pour l'instant les blancs
manoeuvrer expressément dans le but de
justement d'empêcher tout avantage de
mouvements de pions sur cette masse de
pions et immobiliser notamment par ses
deux pièces et le cavalier toujours un
excellent bloqueur donc tout repenser
cette ton concept est sympa c'est super
ben moi j'aime en jeu
j'aime beaucoup cette partie roi et feu
donc c'est très joli alors ça s'enlève
de pourquoi pas de ça mais surtout ça en
est le roi du prix du centre elle joue
avec une grande maîtrise des principes
du jour un magnifique donc tour c4 et la
tranquille pour pas de problème in uk tu
veux me prendre depuis 1 4 shoots on
prend un pion bessette et ça m'ouvrira
la colonne c est ça m'ouvre la colonne
c'est donc en fait il rêver calcul 2
puisque en échange de quoi les blancs
maintenant possède la colonne elle
comprend pas alors une parfaite alors
née en 1931
c'est quand même pas la théorie des
échecs des années 80 90 avec les
ordinateurs les bases de données etc
donc il faut appliquer des principes
fondamentaux mais là ils sont
extrêmement bien appliqué possession
prise de position de colonne ouverte
rapprochement du roi près du centre il
ya tout un tas de facteurs qui sont qui
sont mis en oeuvre si dans cette partie
donc la g5 pour il veut je pense qu'il
va empêcher qu elle le joue elle-même
sans vraiment empêché oui tout à fait
c'est son d'être il veut empêcher alors
l'avantagé 5 c'est que ça tue un peu le
foot ne se fout est mort pour l'instant
bon il peut être recyclé on peut jouer
les trois fous eux 1 et à prévenir par
exemple en banque un prix sur une
magnifique mannequin
donc c'est vrai que le coup j'ai cinq
effectivement de la part des noirs
empêche que les blancs jouent eux-mêmes
g5 pour casser et menacé des par exemple
il faut prendre les quatre qui restent
eux qui laisserait le pion des caps
totalement isolé f3 voyez donc c'est
exactement ce que je disais donc c'est
pas grave
en jouant f3 là les pions qui empêche
les avancées et
besoin l'europe la possibilité de
recycler sont fous donc il n'est pas
finalement pas vraiment enfermé avec ses
deux pions f3 et g4 et d'en contrôler
quasiment 4 et 5 204 6 500 kg avec
l'aide du cavalier depuis tout à fait
tout est verrouillé tour à 2 mais au
retour à deux menaces rien parce que le
pion b2b il a encore le hohneck les
magnifiques bloqueurs il ya à la fois
bloqueur des pions et protecteur de son
camp tour à 20 fois exactement ce que je
disais ça versailles est alors aux
cycles le fou pouf
pourquoi pas un beckham et 4 on sera pas
qui est le fou le cavalier seul cavalier
multiway le petit piège foulée quatre
attaques lecavalier ensuite floue à
trois et on a enfermé la tour a
éventuellement fou à troyes où elle
pourrait sortir par un allons parce
qu'il ya le est à toi oui d'accord tu en
as we fou à trois attaques lecavalier
car les bouges par y en avait huit fois
3 la tour est bloquée et puis cavale et
b4 pouf mais tellement fort et joue à 5
on aurait donc je retourne bien et qui a
laissé un pouf et ça se fera pas parce
que il y aurait le foufou des cinq
puisque ray plus le cavalier en sait-on
pourrait pas le faire on va le faire on
va le faire fin effectivement on va le
faire donc
alors imaginons ah oui mais on peut
jouer à 5 me sur mais imaginons donc
généreux et puis tiens on va essayer
dire tu en veste et de rats cycle et le
roi bon alors fou b4 d'accord imaginons
à 5 pour dire ben maintenant j'ai pas
envie imaginons fonds à troyes aube la
tour est coincé puis on pourrait jouer
simplement fou ici des cinq puisque le
cloud est bloqué et si les rois les
noirs font ce coup on peut envisager
tour b 1 et puis simplement que kazan
est effectivement prises
c'est une des multiples menaces pour à
deux points à 5 parce que la wii donc
j'ai vu ça en fait c'est clairement soir
il a vu que la vue à melun
il n'empêche c'est un coup uniquement
défensif et lincou tranquillement fout
d'eux en fait en gros elle lui dit ben
écoutez coincé à toi f 5 m et c'est
quasiment la zone franc d'ailleurs pour
wes et du besoin parce que leur fils
bronx a rappelé que ça va signifie et
bien tout coup joué par les noirs à
publient leurs positions ouais
ici par exemple le fou peut pas jouer en
1 7 parce que sinon la tour va entrer en
scène
alors si le fou juhasz est simplement
tous ses sets et puis ça y est c'est
fini local est attaqué c'est c'est le
désastre si lecavalier bujumbura fou des
cinq attaques la tour et le pion à vii
donc on ne peut pas bouger en fait un
faux pas bougé cavaliers non plus
puisqu'il retour 6 6 oui mais le
béninois le fou c'est dans tout et
pénible tout extrêmement pénibles dans
quel sens il essaie de se débattre alors
f5 2.95
je sais même pas pourquoi le prend et en
sélectionnant elle pouvait prendre un
peu carrément de prendre un pion en
scène qui sinon la peur d'elle cynisme à
huy à piriac ailleurs il ya aussi fou à
six hommes et la tour est déjà prise en
fait parce que si la toux revient à
quatre roues mais 3 et elle va où ainsi
la viande des cats et l'autre fou donc
en fait foi 6 et la tour est prise alors
au lieu de quoi vont vers meetic fait
plus bon alors peut-être que la tension
née au 40e oui oui on n'est pas loin des
contrôles de temps voilà 40e coup
contrôle de temps donc aussi il faut
tenir compte de ça donc j'ai problème
c'est que c'est toujours écrasant de
toute façon j'ai pris 5 à 4 alors je me
fais un peu n'importe quoi on l'a fait
c'est sûr qu'ils jouaient 5 après il
joue à quatre il sait pas trop ce qu'ils
jouissent d'un droit tranquillement elle
n'est pas pressée elle veut protéger son
fou des deux là une idée en tête je
pense puisqu'après à 3 elle joue b4 ça
c'est joli elle peut jouer des quatre
parce que le roi protège le fou alors b4
intérêts de b4 pour vera benchikh c'est
d'avoir un pion passé et c'est de se
dire mais en fait à tours en est déjà
prise effectivement quand tu disais tout
à l'heure et déjà enfermé puisque le cas
à les protéger de la tour protège ses
deux le roi pour tâche des deux est ici
en bas c'est là pour ses seins qui
protège il suffit maintenant de jouer x
6 pouces et quatre îles à niveau donc on
rêve six noms pourquoi pas et la sai
elle avait une fois ci c'est le recul
joué presque tout à l'heure mais à la
limite c'est pareil en fait foi si ce
pouf
qu'est ce qu'on fait on va où cic moi
j'ai 4 ça n'empêche pas poussé quatre et
ça n'empêche pas fou c4 alors elle prend
pas parce que si elle prenait 2,4 et
bouger le cavalier et là c'est moins
clair donc tous ces cas là tout est
perdu
bon il prend quand même le fou des deux
pour apprendre c'est là vont me dire
qu'ils commencent à faire preuve d' une
légère pointe de misogynie c'est que là
il est quand même à un moment où il ya
une tour de retard
il ya quand même une tour de retard et
il continue à jouer
ce qui veut dire que la norme allemande
dans aucun tournoi moderne des joueurs
de ce niveau là parce que c'était déjà
de très bons joueurs à l'époque continue
une partie on a une tournette de moins
parce que c'est une tournée c'est c'est
injouable
mais sait on né en 1931 et c'est c c'est
une femme qui joue contre nous sommes
alors ça ça peut expliquer ça alors j'ai
pris froid qu'avait laissé 5
alors faut faire attention la poussée e4
parce que ça irait vite sinon si on
laissait le cavalier en d3 oui alors
mais on ne peut pas jouer quatre tout de
suite puisque 1 puisque quelqu'un m'a
dit si on est si on laissait si les
blancs laissés lecavalier en d3 oui le
gâteau trois échecs avec quand même deux
pions menaçant mais même ses pions
serait pas gagnant parce que le fou
contrôle tour contre on ne peut pas
passer comme ça demain devant beaucoup
de pièces un c'est pas possible donc la
laisser scène qui m'envoient là et là
bon il prend à f/5 il espère encore
pouvoir jouer aux cartes et pouvoir
créer une espèce de 2,2 menace ici non
là pas perdre de temps qu'il n'en faut
prendre cette peur de rien food et vite
alors pourquoi food évitant focalise
alors est-ce qu'on peut pas ici tenter
eux quatre essais ont analysé ça qu'est
ce qui se passe sur quatre dans l'allier
prend à huy droit prend et l'enfilade et
la fameuse enfilade échec puisque sur
roy n'en faut faire attention quand même
là il faut faire attention 103,5 et ça
marche parce que sur f2 on a quand même
fou c4 qui permet de protéger la case
3-1 wah wah wah main
alors rouaf il faut faire attention
parce qu'il ya des trois échecs ouais
mais fou ces quatre mois ça me plaît pas
trop parce qu'il ya à 12 non non c'est
pas grave alors poussé quatre alors en
mettant fous ces quatre à deux tours et
cet échec
et voilà il ya échec ici gagne le pion à
f2 tranquille parce que si on prenait
avait le full autres faits d'armes
oui simplement avait d'ailleurs on peut
laisser faire dès maintenant il ferait
cavalier fait que ce serait pénible
donc il vaut mieux d'abord faire un
échec droit bouger par exemple ici on
prend avec deux événements à deux par
deux on prend à deux ça y est c'est fini
puisque le pion il doit il contrôlé par
la tour s'ils avancent l'idée prix voilà
donc là il ya plus de problème donc on
revient en c4 ont contrôlé puis après ce
qu on fait la différence
sens russie donc fou bref c'est donc ici
food et 8,9 bras il protège ça et il
veut jouer e411 et rania plus là-bas la
manoeuvre tout rishek d'accord et là
regardez fou aux six échecs tranquille
alors pourquoi ah oui il peut pas venir
à ces magnifiques qui peut pas venir en
f4 puisque sur f 4 cavaliers des trois
échecs
on peut sans doute jouer effectivement
cavaliers detroit échec et on va loin
s'il vient là pour simhat s'évade seimat
c'est un superbe tableau ces 21es ci
vient pas là mais c'est le plus ancien
qui saute alors là situé au 500 et plus
du tout ma région et les pièces
suffisent à arrêter tout coin donc là
faut s'en aller ici c'est fini quoi
d'accord donc sauf ou six échecs il n'a
pas le choix il peut pas monter henri iv
il faut qu'ils redescendent dans la
maintenance ou g4 attaque f3 qu'on ne
peut pas protéger
donc on fait quoi mais on fait qu'il y
ait des cinq mais ça ne permet pas
d'éviter fou pour un f3 c'est fini c'est
dire que la tentative ne va rien de neuf
là il aurait pu vraiment finir là là il
peut abandonner sur la limite on peut
comprendre qu'ils croient qu'il peut
encore trouver une petite arnaque
alors il est là
je vois pas trop à quoi ils croient
bonus qui croient possible donc prendre
b4 d'accord c'est un gâteau le flou bien
se remettre sur quatre donc ces docteurs
sont verrouillées à ce fou empêche
tentative de bouger le cavalier qui
contrôle aussi les deux cases pourra
revenir éventuellement des trois noms à
tourves à sa mêlée le fou le 4 et domine
complètement le cavalier b4 qui peut
aller lire ses 6 millions des 5
il est encore moins en d3 et lancer deux
fausses est non pourquoi pas cueilli les
trois se pressent pas c'est pas prêt
c'est bien la fin d'une maîtrise ou veut
elle montre une grande maîtrise aussi de
se précipitent pas les os des coups
solides
il n'y a pas de souci alors cavaliers
prends mon cas il ya deux alors sans
doute qu'à lille 2 elle veut pouvoir
qu'est ce qu'elle veut faire ici ah oui
elle veut simplement attaqué le foot
s'il se bouge le fameux la fameuse
intimité avec leucate donc l' échec
c'est joli ça puisque ce rejet
saint-ours échec alors regardez il peut
pas bouger parce que là là c'est le
cavalier qui protège la c'est le fou
donc il faut qu'ils viennent sur sur la
rangée ici rush 4 et pouf ça y est bonne
on a encore éliminé un pion et puis ça
sent presque le tableau de matelas ça
sent le tableau de maths après cavale et
c3 simplement voies des trains et c'est
fini c'est fini mais plus rien or bien
on peut une pièce qu'ils passion pousse
à deux touches par exemple la gtoi 1,6
ou sinon nous touche énormément peu
importe un touché je ne sais pas toi si
c'est bien
bon alors quoi qu'il en soit il ya plus
grand chose à espérer pour les normands
c'est fini tout raciste de soissons
qu'est ce qu'on va jouer mais n'en fout
des 5 1 mais on peut parier label
cavaliers leroy prendre les quatre on
peut jouer ça
enfin l'ailier g6 on va pas passer là
dessus quand une tour de moindres
effectivement on voit que peuvent quand
même la comptine une partie qui est
archi perdante avec une tour de moins
bons un peu disons qu effectivement à
l'époque il n'était pas forcément sûr de
la force de miramichi qu il voulait
l'attesté communiants puis là il voulait
pas faire partie du club et ramène chic
oui la question de réputation donc on
fait partie donc est en fait partie
voilà c'est le membre le plus célèbre
quasiment rien eu on a ignoré chiefs qui
est pas mal aux yeux et qui s'est lui
aussi laissé le seul championnat c'est
ce champion du monde quand même et tout
à fait donc mal partis quand même un de
vers à mennecy donc là une des premières
vraies championne d'échecs
car jouer donc comme tu l'as dit qu'elle
fait une deuxième capablanca il n'y a
pas beaucoup de gens qui peuvent se
targuer ressasser ils sont ils peuvent
se compter sur les doigts d'une seule
main je pense même d'ailleurs sûrement
le décès de robert simmons et qui donc
ici bas un champion du monde dès les
années 30 et qui est une des précurseurs
des échecs au film et qui aujourd'hui
explose avec 4 ailes en nombre de grands
maîtres féminin dans le top dans le top
mondial
merci jérôme pour cette plongée dans
l'histoire du jeu d'échecs avec cette
magnifique joueuses verra benchikh dont
on vous invite à regarder les autres
partout et elles sont disponibles dans
les bases de données vous en trouver sur
internet sur partout vers amène chic et
vous pourrez regarder comment sais tu
joues et n'a pu battre les meilleurs
joueurs du monde de son époque avec
talent comme dans cette partie superman
et je pense que c'est une partie
vraiment à l'entrée dans les écoles elle
est vraiment
typique de ce qu'il faut faire pour
battre un joueur qui ne respecte pas les
principes fondamentaux avec talent à
bientôt sur terre monatélé pour d'autres
émissions sur les grands champions
bientôt au revoir